you
well beginning design thinking can be
done in many ways and many schools many
schools of thought have battled it in a
variety of ways but the two extremes
constitute one is engagement in the
world in all of its synthesis in all of
its complexity and all of its mess and
trying to work through design issues by
incorporating them but the other
approach which is something we have
tried to adopt in our most recent
thinking is to edit and at least
initially to begin to think that
architecture if only temporarily needs
to be absolved of all of that pressure
and take on singular issues at a time so
in for instance in the core program we
may take the issue of structure
engineering being so central to the
architectural question as one of the
core points of an exercise and even at
the risk of failure of all of the other
constituencies around it all of the
other contingencies around it all of the
other considerations to radicalize the
students knowledge in that domain that
same thing may happen with problems of
programming problems of circulation
problems of urbanism but in a way you
end up with an initial education that
atrophies 10 things in order to in a way
raise the stakes of one enterprise
well the current moment needs to be
looked at within a broader framework
probably the way in which the Industrial
Revolution has given way to the digital
revolution is changing things radically
even the idea of the internet and the
accessibility to education the way that
we learn is not necessarily from a
teacher but from somebody in another
city who happens to be in a junior
program much younger than yourself
the way we learn is just very different
now so and then that has also led to a
revolution in terms of production we
build through digital media now and that
changes the way that you design things
all of this has changed the way that we
instruct in the earlier years and the
later years in addition to that
obviously the question of sustainability
has become up front and center for a
great range of people and that's another
debate to be had but it is of some
concern so there are let's say a range
of issues that have changed the focus
from a global level and because of that
one may say that there's two tendencies
one is again how you incorporate the
world into education the other one is
how do you look at those irreducible
aspects of the architectural Mattia or
the architectural tradition without
which we don't we can't consider
ourselves as a discipline